Hi, this is Craig Glenday, editor-in-chief of Guinness World Records 2011.
Earlier this year, Guinness World Records invited a handful of record holders to Rome...
...to film a TV series for the Italians.
Among the giants, dwarves, hairy families, and daredevil stuntmen that turned up,...
...one talent stood out for his unique abilities.
He was Francisco Domingo Joaquin.
And don't worry if you find his name a bit of a mouthful, you can call him Chiquinho.
He holds the Guinness World Records certificate for, yes you guessed it,...
...the world's widest mouth.
This jaw-dropping talent from Sambizanga in Angola,...
...was discovered by Guinness World Records researchers while scouting Youtube for new talent.
After the two-year hunt, we finally tracked him down to a marketplace in his hometown...
...and were able to measure his massive mouth.
At 17 centimeters wide, that's just over six and a half inches,...
...Chiquinho's mouth is big enough to fit a drink's can in sideways.
And as for his ability to stretch his lips over his face...
...well, that's a unique talent we can safely say we've never seen before.